hallo meine lieben freunde extrem viele
von euch haben uns meine letzten
whatsapp fell videos geschrieben dass
sie unbedingt einen neuen partner von
sehen wollen von daher herzlich
willkommen hier heute nicht richtig zu
whatsapp feld sondern zu einigen
nachrichten die aus versehen an die
falsche person geschickt wurden bzw
einfach an die falsche nummer
und ich würde sagen wir fangen direkt an
mit dieser nachricht hier und zwar dort
eine person geschrieben einen pregnant
und die andere person hat einfach
geantwortet communications einen link
den raum hamburg
[Applaus]
das hier ist der nächste whatsapp fail
und zwar wird dort eine person
geschrieben jessica fragezeichen dann
berichtet er sich nochmals schreibt
jessica mit doppel s und die person
antwortet einfach das hier als von ihm
und er ist auch bescheinigt man
unterschreibt nur ein look alike jessica
nein du siehst nicht aus wie jessicas
jetzt die nächste nachricht die eine
person fälschlicherweise bekommen hat
und zwar hell marry me to come inn
vorher kadlec neue teamchef und die
person antwortet einfach will egal ob
die styles work for you can also
komplett gesteuerte figuren die person
schreibt dann are no und dann die andere
person wieder wenn ihr schon protocol
mary instanz also von wegen hey wenn ihr
meine frisuren nicht taugen dann ruft
doch einfach wirklich mary an oder
schreibt der richtigen nummer und
schreibt nicht mir genauso darum geht es
doch eigentlich bei dem nächsten chat
verlauf hier und zwar schreibt dort eine
person hey dieses maria und schickt hat
ein bild von mir was jetzt mal zensiert
wurde die person antwort allerdings
helau
das ist ok maria antwortet hat wurde ab
ist wird j
ich will die leute da ist die stadt hier
nicht raus kommt übrigens am ersten
zwölfter in den drucker wieder von vorne
steht keep smiling drauf und auf der
rückseite haltung text und wegen hey
lass dich nicht unterkriegen und sonst
bei dir so ein bisschen verwaschen
ja ja wahrscheinlich was mein bauch und
nicht meinen rücken
allerdings finde ich auf jeden fall mehr
leute dazu sagen quasi einfach
mitspielen und dann halt wirklich da
einfach ja mitspielen
hier wird sich meine machen allerdings
weiter mit dem nächsten chat verlauf und
zwar ist es dass hier eine person
bekommt die nachricht hallo wer bist du
und sie schreibt eine tochter
mama also die mutter hat ihrer tochter
eine nachricht geschrieben und fragte
hallo wer bist du eine tochter schreibt
dann allerdings einfach so hey ich bin
deine tochter die mama schreibt
daraufhin allerdings dass hier das muss
ein irrtum sein ich hab nur eine und die
tochter gesteckt und sagt man mal das
ist meine neue nummer und allgemein
sondern mysterium was chat verläufe
angeht ich habe halt selber so ein
bisschen angst dass ich irgendwann auch
so werde das sich somit technik nicht
mehr richtig klar komme weil sich das
alles weiterentwickelt
aber gut ich würde sagen wir machen
direkt weiter mit dem nächsten match
etwas das hier havixbecker der holdorf
eurogate million you never really want
to apologize for schnitt gingen in new
york bei new opel stream of hate you
have attempted 1 o in paris und einfach
los
ja ich glaube das war ziemlich peinlich
dass jetzt die nächste nachricht die
fälschlicherweise an diese personen
geschickt wurde und zwar schreibt die
person hey you free on tuesday movie
aufs amt den oder antwortet dem reiter
im free dies ist amerika und ein bild
von einem adler vor einer amerika flagge
genau das weiß ich dass die leute da so
richtig mitspielen einfach und genau das
gleiche jetzt auch hier bei diesem
schnellen verlauf der fall und zwar
sehen die schon dass hier eine person
eine gruppe erstellt hat in der sie ein
foto mit ihrem neugeborenen kind
hochlädt und eine person
fälschlicherweise in der gruppe und
schreibt einfach haggis met you this is
crazy you have them but not that baby
also er zitiert
schreibt mir gerne in die kommentare wie
das lied noch mal heißt nach weil doch
direkt weiter mit dem nächsten
nachrichten veh und zwar es ist das hier
ein junge schreibt hey baby heimspiel in
monaco war also ein foto von sich
oberkörper frei und er hat ja nicht
falsch nummer geschickt wer hätte das
gedacht bei dem heutigen video thema
luca das jetzt auch weil ich bau dir
bekommen hat dann das brother und ein
foto von sich und der zeit als das ding
ist halt wenn ich so eine nachricht
bekommen würde ich wird die person
einfach blockieren
ich will bedenken nervt mich nicht
werden aber genauso war es auch hier in
dem fall und zwar sehen wir wieder ein
foto wo eine person gut trainiert ein
foto verschickt und die andere person
antwortet einfach
er schreibt jetzt mybet aber ich würde
dort nie foto zurückschicken weil wir
nun allerdings wieder zu einem chat
fällen wo es um die mutter geht und zwar
schreibt eine person in einer anderen
person diese nachricht namen once you
tube call hören also mama will dass du
sie anruft und die andere person
schreibt einfach kuh ist dies hat die
person von der die nachricht gesendet
wurde nach irgendwie zwei stunden oder
so geschrieben entriss und daraufhin die
andere nummer raum numbers and you got
me in anders ist verriet die minis
konversation mit my mother softbank you
forget also die person dachte hey die
person kennt mich da die schreibt die
zwei meine mutter anrufen das heißt ich
rufe jetzt mal meine mutter an und die
haben dann eine halbe stunde telefoniert
aufgrund von irgendwelchen im nächsten
spiel geht es ausnahmsweise mal nicht um
die mutter die da irgendwie mit
reingezogen wird oder um ein halbes
nacktfoto was falsch verschickt wurde
sondern es geht um ein kabel die person
schreibt das ist der standard cable und
die andere person antwortet einfach das
ist das standard cat guist und dann
wurde die andere person einfach harro
personals kat und wo wir gerade schon
bei katzen waren hier geht es um hunde
meiner lieben freund und zwar schon den
ganzen chat verlauf eingeblendet eine
person schickt ein foto von hundewelpen
erscheint allerdings direkt rang numbers
also checkt direkt helm waren die
falsche nummer
die andere person jux allerdings nicht
und sie schreibt way beyond worden und
dann die andere person wieder des labors
liste web servers also die number die
oder ihm gegeben für einen tierarzt die
person gibt es allerdings wieder nicht
und er scheidet good care of dogs for
free die person stadt eher schleppend
selfish also ja ich finde da kommt man
schon mal ein hund abgeben
im nächsten schritt geht es darum dass
eine junge die nummer eines mädchens
bekommen hat und er schreibt sie einfach
an mit sophie also ganz normal der
nachricht die sophie antwortet with this
daraufhin die anderen nummern all you
gave me your number no more than five
minutes ago daraufhin schreibt
allerdings so viel action game numbers
oder schickt er wird das foto ein ort
viel böses war gar nicht so wie ja das
tut weh passt auch weh tut ist wenn du
diese nachricht an eine falsche person
schreibt und zwar erkennt helfer trinken
incredibly amazing und wonderful torsten
just saying also eher besteht quasi
einer anderen person seine liebe die
alle personen schreibt allerdings ron
hubbard whether you think you all that
wasn't for me also egal wer du bist ich
tue einfach so als wäre es für mich
gewesen
sehr schöne antwort denn hitze chat
verlauf ist ja ich zeige es euch einfach
mal und zwar wurde dort diese nachricht
eine person geschickt ok power baut we
have ja die andere person schreibt you
ist es dann schreibt die person wieder
ein mixed by numbers ab sorry und dann
schickt er war zurückgesetzt
das ist einfach einen verdammten
polizist hinterm steuer
machen wir doch direkt weiter mit dem
nächsten whatsapp chat famous ich glaube
das war gar nicht wie allgemein sind so
viele sachen die ich in what's up
entstanden aber jeder weiß bei whatsapp
tales was gemeint ist deswegen dem titel
what's up dates oder vielleicht etwas
anders im titel
ich weiß es nicht wir machen auf jeden
fall weiter mit dem chat fällen zwar
schreibt dort eine person die andere
person schreibt auch heidi aller person
schreibt wieder heim
dann schreibt ihr alle personen ressort
also herr das wird jetzt gerade bisschen
komisch schreibt die an personen also
wie
diese leute die das ist der nächste chat
feld und zwar bekommt eine person die
nachricht du willst also wer ist da und
er schickt einfach ein foto von einem
hund zurück dann schreibt ja noch mal
usb stick wieder ein foto von einem hund
und dann schreibt die understanding the
pictures of the cat und ich weiß nicht
ob ich dumm bin und meine augen strotzen
aber dass das ist doch ein hund mit
diesen ohren oder kommen wir jetzt
allerdings zu einer nachricht die
komplett an die falsche person
verschickt wurde und zwar ist es diese
nachricht hier die nachricht ging
nämlich an die mutter seht ihr schon
oben an mami und die person schreibt
schatz
wenn kunst heim ich warte schon auf die
ich also es ist anscheinend
schweizerdeutsch und österreich ich weiß
es nicht genau
geschickt auf jeden fall dieses foto was
ich euch leider zensieren muss weil sie
dort auch leicht bekleidet steht und ich
möchte dass das video werbe freundlich
bleibt dann gefällt die allerdings
nachher selbst auf oh shit sorry mami
ich würde die vig sie bei noemi ich
verstehe kein einziges wort
aber sie wollte das glaub ich an ihren
freund kevin schicken hat es allerdings
aus erzählt ihre mutter geschickt wenn
ihr aus der schweiz kommt übersetzt mir
das geld in den kommentaren allerdings
will ich sagen kommen wir nur noch zum
letzten chat fällt uns was dieser hier
ihr seht schon die erste nacht des fuß
bis er schreibt bei also warum fragst
mich welche ist ihre person schreibt
girl und er schreibt eine grill
also er ist ein grill dann fragt ja eine
person innovation namen und der schreibt
george foreman diane personen schreibt
dort die world grill und er schreibt
einfach also was lernen wir daraus meine
damen und herren könnten nicht nur mit
jungs schreiben auch nicht mit mädels
sondern eventuell auch mit einem grill
stellt euch das video ist allerdings
auch beenden meine lieben freunde wenn
ihr euch heute mal wieder whatsapp chat
fans gefallen hat das unbedingt einen
daumen hoch unter dem video wir da
abonniert zudem einen kanal wenn ihr
wollt dass nicht eventuell demnächst mal
ein nächstes video hierzu hochladen
es gibt so unfassbar viele whatsapp chat
fails allgemein stadtfeld also ja
abonniert gerne einen kanal wenn ihr das
sehen wollt und ich beende das video mit
dieser nachricht dass diese frage die
ich noch auf gutefrage.net gefunden habe
es geht halt darum dass jemand aus
versehen eine nachricht an die falsche
person geschickt hat und das kann für
wahrheit vor fünf jahren da konnte man
whatsapp nachrichten und nicht
zurückziehen der apg und eine person die
ihn darauf geantwortet
als lösung hat einfach geschrieben wlan
ausschalten entweder ein neues handy
kaufen oder du nimmst du irgendwann mal
sein handy und machst dann dein wlan an
und löst die nachricht heimlich bist
halt mal vorstellen
so war das bei mir früher ich meine
mittlerweile kannst halt einfach auch
bei instagram nachrichten zurückrufen
die du irgendwie vorjahren geschickt
hast oder keine ahnung was aber früher
gab es einfach nicht diese funktion
ich denke einfach nur so hey wir haben
wir das überlebt ich schick so oft
nachts irgendwelche bescheuerten
nachrichten.at egal ich möchte einmal
langen zu klammern das video ist jetzt
vorbei
[Musik]